[Musique]
werner herzog vous êtes réalisateur
scénariste producteur acteur c'est un
grand plaisir de vous avoir avec nous il
se passe tant de choses en ce moment
c'est le 75e anniversaire de la fin de
la seconde guerre mondiale vous êtes né
en plein milieu de la seconde guerre
mondiale vous avez grandi dans
l'allemagne d'après guerre
vous avez été le témoin de nombreux
bouleversements pendant votre vie
pensez vous que la psychologie
collective de l'humanité a profondément
évolué depuis la seconde guerre mondiale
aux corses bien sûr cela fait soixante
quinze ans maintenant nous avons avancé
depuis mai nous vivons un écho de notre
passé il ya toujours un fort écho les
souvenirs de la fin de la seconde guerre
mondiale of the sake mme beaudoin exclut
tout en fait généralement nos souvenirs
commencent quand nous avons cinq ou six
ans mais mes tous premiers souvenirs
date de quand j'avais deux ans et demi x
c'était très peu de temps seulement deux
semaines peut-être trois semaines avant
la fin de la guerre avant la
capitulation de l'allemagne
je me souviens que ma mère nous avait
soudain réveillé mon grand frère et moi
même en plein milieu de la nuit
il faisait froid il y avait toujours de
la neige dehors
elle nous a enveloppé dans des
couvertures
pris dans ses bras et a mené sur la
colline derrière la maison et l'a dit
les garçons ont regardé je suis désolé
de vous réveiller mais il faut vous
voyez cela la ville de rosenheim est en
flammes et la ville de rosenheim que
nous connaissions c est une grande ville
à 50 60 km et l'autre mère a dit la
ville de rosenheim brûle on a regardé
vers le fond de la vallée et c'était
d'une telle
quand vous regardez un feu vous voyez
les flammes vaciller c'était tellement
loin c'était tellement grand ce que
c'était comme si le ciel dans son
ensemble été pris d'un battement orange
rouge jaune
il battait lentement un ciel comme celui
là c'est le silence absolu
je savais que quelque chose d'important
se dérouler là bas je n'avais que deux
ans et demi je savais que c'était
important je savais que c'était
dangereux que le monde était différent
de celui qu'on avait connue jusque là je
suis alors devenu curieux de savoir ce
qui se passait dans le monde
un autre souvenir peu après quand les
américains sont arrivés l'allemagne
s'écrouler encore et encore à l'est la
russie commençait son occupation et
gagner des batailles alors qu'à l'ouest
se trouvaient les anglais les français
les américains et la zone de la bavière
où j'ai grandi a été l'un des derniers
territoires à être occupé avant d'être
envahi par les américains je me souviens
du regard de ma mère la première fois
que je me suis retrouvé face à un homme
noir
c'était quelque chose qu'on ne
connaissait que des contes de fées les
morts d hommes noirs comme l'ébène il y
avait un afro américain
il était très très costaud c'était un
genre de shaquille o'neal le basketteur
très imposante très fort très lourd de
football et il avait une voix
merveilleuse
ma mère me regardait assis à côté lui
derrière la maison je lui parler pendant
des heures ce ensuite elle m'a demandé
de qui il s'agissait
j'ai répondu que c'était un homme
fabuleux mais j'ai rencontré un noir et
il est formidable il avait une voix
extrêmement douce une voix magnifique
je me souviens de cette voie je savais
alors que les noirs les africains
étaient des gens merveilleux et puis ça
s'est enraciné en mois et jusqu'à
maintenant quand je vois un noir
je vois une sorte de shaquille o'neal
comme ce premier noir que j'ai rencontré
dans ma vie
mais voilà donc les souvenirs personnels
qui vont accompagner toute votre vie
il ya tant de petits garçons qui comme
vous sont nés pendant la guerre ou qui
ont vécu la seconde guerre dans son
ensemble croyez-vous d'un point de vue
nom personnel mais de celui de la
psychologie collective que quelque chose
a changé pour les gens en 75 ans pensez
vous que la psychologie collective a
évolué depuis la seconde guerre mondiale
et si oui eh bien oui elle a évolué
malheureusement il me faut encore parler
de moi même
j'appartiens à une génération qui a
grandi dans des ruines nous ne
connaissions que le désastre le pays
dans son ensemble toutes les villes
avaient été bombardées et n'étaient plus
que cendres et débris tous ceux de ma
génération tous mes pairs et moi même
nous comprenions que quelque chose
n'allait pas nous avons donc jeter un
regard sur ce qui s'était passé il était
tout à fait évident ça ne faisait pas
débat c'est est clair le fascisme
n'était pas quelque chose de réel tant
que nous serions en vie et il est bien
sûr inquiétant de voir le racisme
ressurgir et constate une montée de
l'antisémitisme du fascisme aux deux
mouvements de type ultra droite et nous
savons que c'est dangereux
nous devons être particulièrement
vigilants vous savez il ya environ deux
ans en 2018
une fondation allemande a mené une étude
qui devait observer le regard des
allemands sur le passé et près de la
moitié de ceux qui ont pris part on dit
qu'il pensait que quelque chose comme
l'holocauste ne se reproduirait plus
quand j'en ai parlé à des amis juifs ils
m'ont dit eh bien nous ne sont pas si
sûr de ça car les gens ont besoin qu'on
leur rappelle en permanence les
atrocités que nous avons traversées pour
que cela n'arrive plus jamais qu'en
pensez vous
considérez vous que les résultats de
cette enquête selon lesquels les gens
considèrent que cela n'arrivera plus
jamais sont une bonne indication et que
effectivement cela n'arrivera plus ou
devons-nous faire quelque chose en plus
pour que les gens aient toujours cela en
tête
eh bien je ne suis pas un prophète
quand vous dites plus jamais je peux
répondre ainsi pas tant que je serai en
vie
in the currency je suis une garantie si
longue et si oui tant que vous verrez
tant que vous m'entendrez cela
n'arrivera pas c'est aussi simple que ça
si nous assistons à un coup d'état
fasciste et qu un holocauste doit avoir
lieu je prendrai les armes je défendrai
la démocratie j'essayerai et je perdrais
sans doute mais je ne serai plus en vie
lorsqu'il y aura un second le costume et
si l'homme tant que je respire ça
n'arrivera pas car je me battrai
activement actifs
je prendrai les armes et combat tracy et
quand je serai mort seulement ça
arrivera encore c'est une réaction
claire faure une réponse très honnête et
je vous en remercie
mais j'aimerais que nous abordions
ensemble la nature humaine comporte
nombre d' atrocités qui ont été commises
par le passé
la violence collective d'un peuple
envers un autre peuple est quelque chose
qui ne disparaît pas je veux dire peu
importe à quel point le son est voulu et
technologiquement
nous sommes toujours été moins de
violence nous pensez vous que viennent
cette tendance fondamentale à être
brutal envers les autres s l'instinct de
survie est ce autre chose
pourquoi elles sont nous peu importe le
degré de notre révolution
je pense que depuis des siècles et des
siècles les scientifiques les
philosophes les religions essaye de
trouver une réponse mais nous n'avons
pas de réponse absolument nous n'avons
que des preuves
nous avons des preuves depuis le début
de l'existence d' homo sapiens des
preuves des violences entre les hommes
qui lie à des squelettes de l'époque de
cro magnon qui ont des pointes de flèche
dans les vertèbres la guerre existait
déjà
[Musique]
il ya des peintures dans des cavernes
par exemple dans le sud du sahara qui
dépeignent des scènes de conflits entre
humains comme flic des conflits armés
des batailles entre hommes iboot je ne
dirais pas que c'est là notre nature
collectif mais collectivement nous ne
sommes pas débarrassé de la violence la
violence individuelle oui les crimes les
meurtres c'est malheureusement quelque
chose qui arrive mais la question est
beaucoup plus vaste
est-ce que cela existe dans la nature
humaine collective ou non personne n'a
de réponse satisfaisante pour le moment
mais bien sûr il faut être très prudent
en particulier à partir du moment où
nous avons des instruments extrêmement
dangereux des armes atomiques des armes
biologiques guise
[Musique]
la première guerre mondiale a été une
catastrophe parce que soudain la guerre
s'est industrialisée les armes et se
retrouvait sur le champ de bataille au
début de la guerre avec une sorte
d'esprit chevaleresque nous sommes
courageux et brave et nous nous battrons
comme au moyen âge avec une épée et un
bouclier et soudain les fusils
mitrailleurs les bombes l'artillerie
lourde et la guerre aérienne
le choc a été très très profond
le choc de l'holocauste lui a été très
profond d'abord parce que c'était sans
précédent si nos précédentes il n'y a
pas de précédent dans l'histoire
mondiale
il n'ya pas non plus de mots pour
décrire ces horreurs bien ce terme aux
low cost mais ça n'est pas une
description réaliste ce qui était
particulièrement choquant était que ce
meurtre de masse ce génocide était
industriels
c'est le meurtre de masse industrielle
de six millions de juifs en parlant d'
atrocités comme l'holocauste
qu'est ce qui déclenche dans l'esprit
humain la capacité à faire des atrocités
de ce genre tout en étant convaincu de
faire ce qui est nécessaire c'est une
question très complexe
ce collectif finale mais je pense que
c'est en partie lié
aujourd'hui où à l'époque des nazis peu
importe
à la question de qui détient le cours du
récit collectif qui est à l'origine de
la diabolisation
que ce soit des juifs des français des
russes
peu importe on le voit très clairement
aujourd'hui ce n'est pas tant une
question de qui détient le récit
collectif et il nous faut être très
prudent quand on se penche sur les
médias que font les médias qu y at il
une sorte de lavage de cerveau collectif
en cours au nom corinne gorse 90
c'est là que nous nous trouvons il faut
en être conscient
il faut être vigilant et penser par soi
même
nous allons faire une courte pause avant
de reprendre notre conversation avec le
légendaire réalisateur scénariste et
producteur werner herzog au sujet de la
nature humaine pendant la guerre
restez avec nous
[Musique]
et nous voilà de retour avec le
légendaire réalisateur werner herzog
werner vous savez l'un d'eux mais
philosophe allemand préféré hannah
arendt disais que des pires crimes
contre l'humanité était commis par des
gens banal médiocre a qui se sont tout
simplement retrouvé pris par les
méandres de l'histoire et on fait ce
qu'il considérait comme nécessaire sans
se poser vraiment de questions net aux
monstres ou le devient ton selon les
circonstances
ce complexe
je pense que c'est une combinaison
complexe de facteurs mais hannah arendt
a souligné il me semble que c'est la
première à l'avoir fait remarquer la
banalité du mal c'est une observation
très juste parce que souvent tout cela
commence avec des banalités dans ces
faibles d existence médiocre 6 tennis et
si ces dernières finissent par avoir le
pouvoir
soudain le cocktail devient extrêmement
dangereux
nos grands parents sont allés au front
en 1939 il n'y avait rien
d'extraordinaire ça je veux dire pendant
des siècles le faire la guerre de
manière traditionnelle a aidé quelque
chose qu'il fallait juste faire de temps
à autre maintenant après 75 ans de paix
relative
pensez vous que la guerre telle qu'ils
n'ont connu est une option viable pour
la psyché européenne contemporaine ou
qu'elle a muté en quelque chose de
différent ce qui était le cas pour nos
grands-parents n'existe plus ils ont été
surpris par l'industrialisation pendant
la première guerre mondiale
ça a été le plus gros choc je pense mais
aujourd'hui le scénario est différent
parce qu'il y à l'arme nucléaire et des
systèmes de tirs très efficace
je trouve que le fait que les armes de
courte et moyenne portée soit de retour
est très préoccupant je pense que c'est
très dangereux et je considère que la
russie appartient culturellement à
l'europe
je n'avais pas trouvé tout à fait
étrange pendant un instant qu'on pense à
inclure la russie dans l'otan ils
connaissent bien sûr cela avait des
répercussions très complexe est ce que
l'otan défendrait la russie disons s'il
devait y avoir un conflit en extrême
orient dans le pacifique avec la chine
etc
c'est trop complexe mais l'idée selon
laquelle la russie nous appartient
quand je dis nous j'entends par là
l'europe ce que la poésie nous
appartient n'est pas erroné
j'ai entendu dire que la guerre était le
meilleur moyen de découvrir qui nous
étions vraiment mettant à nu notre vraie
nature vous avez fait des documentaires
sur la guerre vous avez fait des films à
ce sujet quelles sont les principales
découvertes que vous avez faite
concernant la nature humaine
tout il me faut mentionner l'un d'eux la
balade du petit soldat
un film que j'ai tourné au nicaragua
avec les miis quito des rebelles
indigènes c'était principalement au
sujet d'enfants-soldats des enfants de 8
9 10 11 ans la guerre menée par les
enfants qui peuvent faire la guerre il
est facile de se servir d'une arme
iseli ils peuvent se servir des outils
de guerre ils n'ont pas à être grand ou
fort physiquement la tragédie des
guerres menées par des enfants est
particulièrement pénible qu'une discrète
et dans le cas du nicaragua
notre propre à cannes ce n'est pas la
propagande qui les y amener chaussettes
fils ce sont les atrocités que leur
famille ont subi des familles décimées
fond des mers tué devant leur enfant de
huit ans le lendemain ils rejoignent les
insurgés ce sont des tragédies
individuelles des tragédies personnelles
une bébête show this is it when you et
je pense que quand on se penche sur la
guerre sur ce qui pousse l'individu à
faire la guerre on se retrouve face à la
propaganda et aux expériences
personnelles c'est ce que l'on voit dans
les guerres dans lesquelles des enfants
sont impliqués
en afrique on voit cela assez souvent
fou
vos produits seriez vous d'accord pour
dire que lorsqu'une guerre frappe
elle fait ressortir le pire comme le
meilleur chez les gens ce que je veux
dire c'est que à chaque fois qu'on
entend parler de trahison aux deux
meurtres pour la survie il ya en
parallèle l'histoire de quelqu'un qui
sauf quelqu'un d'autre d'un soldat se
précipitant sur une grenade d'une
famille risquant qui pour un fugitif de
tende allemands qui ont risqué leur vie
pour cacher des juifs chez eux
vous voyez ce que je veux dire ce n'est
pas quelque chose que l'on fait au
quotidien
je pense que quand il ya quelque chose
de cette ampleur
tout ce qui est en nous les biens comme
le mâle ressort modus ou du sel est ce
que je me trompe je vais vous dire
quelque chose que je pense regardons ce
qui se passe en ce moment cette pandémie
ce qu vie 19
regardons comment nous y réagissant
parce qu'il me semble bien que cette
pandémie est comme une troisième guerre
mondiale
nous nous battons tous le monde entier
contre un ennemi invisible des standards
et avez vous le sentiment que cette
pandémie a changé les gens s'en moquent
parce que je vois des gens cons comme
pendant les guerres du passé est énorme
il n'y aura en faisant des choses à
considérer pendant que d'autres sauve
des vies
et on ne voit pas cela au quotidien
la bouteille est ce que oui
passons à la pandémie parce que bien sûr
pour notre génération c'est quelque
chose de tout à fait nouveau n'avons pas
vu cela depuis 1917 1919 nous n'avons
pas connu la peste comme au moyen âge et
pendant l'antiquité mais oui ça va
changer notre comportement collectif
pour le moment il n'y a qu'une seule
option celle de la discipline s'était
spleen
il nous faut nous séparer et nous isoler
pour battre ce virus pour éviter la
contamination
il nous faut le réduire à néant c'est
bien sûr au delà de la discipline
il nous faut espérer qu'on trouve un
vaccin alors les choses changeront tout
changerait à partir de ce moment là mais
de bonnes choses ressortent
je le ressens dans notre quartier je
vois comment on s'aide les uns les
autres
comment nous comprenons les choses de
manière collective
ce qui est difficile à comprendre et la
propagation la propagation du virus ne
relève pas de notre expérience habituel
quand vous marchez dans la rue vous
voyez une personne puis une deuxième
puits numéro 3 numéros 4 etc
mais le virus ne fonctionne pas comme
cela
il n'est pas linéaire vous croisez 16
personnes et le chiffre suivant n'est
pas le 17 mai soudainement le 32 joue
sur les deux shows à 32 possibilité de
contamination existe est le suivant
n'est pas 33 mais 64 64 possibilité de
contamination existe de nouveaux et
c'est ensuite 128 et soudain en l'espace
de quelques kilomètres on est à un
million
ce n'est pas notre expérience habituel
des chiffres et il faut en tirer des
leçons
c'est pourquoi à l'heure actuelle nous
devons faire preuve de discipline mais
tout était simple pour conclure cette
conversation vous en tant que
visionnaire en tant qu artiste qui a une
vision vous faites des films où vous
êtes inspirés par des images comment
diriez vous que cette pandémie va
transformer l'humanité
comment feriez vous si vous aviez à le
transcrire dans un nouveau film
calciomercato je ne pense pas devoir en
faire un film
mais imaginons eye to believe tête
je pense que cela montre que certaines
choses sont réalisables collectif les
doubles nous pouvons changer certains de
nos comportements fondamentaux il n'est
pas question de faire un gigantesque
sommer de modifier notre comportement et
du lys on peut observer des comportement
héroïque vous j'ai vu à la télévision
des gens qui étaient les premiers à
vouloir prendre part à une étude une
quête et être infectées dans le virus
fait pour tester des médicaments
ces héros sortent des rangs de la
société des gens tout à fait ordinaire
ils sortent des rangs et 10 cela doit
être fait et je serai volontaire donnez
moi ce virus et testons votre vaccin je
trouve que c'est un comportement des
plus civique des plus héroïques chess ce
n'est pas un simple geste ces gens
peuvent en mourir
et seuls les morts sont des héros merci
verner pour cette interview pour ces
éclaircissements passionnant j'espère
vraiment qu'on aura l'occasion de nous
revoir
mais ça a été une grande bouffée d'air
frais que de vous parler alors qu'on
fait le 75e anniversaire de la victoire
une chose sujet de la russie la russie a
perdu plus de 25 millions de soldats et
de civils
[Musique]
ce sont les seuls vrais héros ceux qui
ont sacrifié leur vie sont des héros il
ya plus de 25 millions de héros dont il
faut honorer la mémoire
je regrette que l'allemagne est engendré
un tel désastre pour le peuple russe
marchi pipi patch mais aujourd'hui tout
est possible je suis marié à une russe
est très heureux en espérant que vous
restiez maria une belle femme russe pour
encore des années merci infiniment et
bonne journée de la victoire prenez soin
de vous merci à vous merci infiniment
[Musique]